feels the nationals first of three the
orioles won the suspended game
earlier today they took that game six to
two
and now they try to get after the
nationals will have their big three on
the mount in this series let's take a
look at the
he did a wonderful job of pitching
inside with just a below average
fastball
he pitched enough inside the nationals
and it made his change up down away very
effective we'll see what kind of
adjustments he has to make
one-two pitch and eaton's down on
strikes steven
one start that was against the orioles
orioles roughed him up a little bit in
that fifth inning but boy he had a heck
of a year last year career year 18 wins
that led the national league career high
and starts career high and strikeouts
with 251 and he carried that to the
postseason
anthony santander at the plate started
the day
tied for second in the american league
with 19 rbis
high fly ball deep right field eaton
fading back
at the track looking up and it's gone
anthony santander he's not behind
anybody in rbis now that gives him 20
and his fifth home of the year gives the
orioles a lead
fastball up and away paul lessard and
davey martinez i mean they're seeing
what i'm seeing
obviously what we're seeing
if it ain't right don't take a chance he
knows that
pause the body language didn't look
right yeah see how he jerked it and
then shakes the elbow so that just tells
me that that nerve is still
inflamed that's why i just think it's a
why take a chance i said it in the open
before the rain delay
there's no need to take a risk with your
career if it's not
right shut it down
[Applause]
off the glove of malone into center
field that made a loud sound
out to left center garcia
screaming around second so wet outfield
so tonight you got to go hard first to
third because once an outfielder picks
up the ball out there at p anything can
happen
if john gomez can answer the homer right
here
there it is ball's got to get down and
it does
and now ki boom should be able to score
all the way around from first
gomes heading around the bases he's
going to end up
at third john gomes a two-out
triple soto now in scoring position with
two down
howie he's going to get jammed and drop
one to right field
soto scoring easily and the nets lead
four to one i'm loving the dugout sound
effects man this is awesome
are we kendrick rbi number five oh look
at that
and the dugout likes that one too
howie will stop at second first major
league hit
for luis garcia get the ball yes sir
congratulations luis garcia great
approach
kibu the seventh nap to bet in the end
and rips one to left howie kendrick
coming around third
chugging home throw way off line
and the nets lead five to one
so here's has dribbled the switch hitter
so here's as dribble the switch hitter
as dribble look rounder to second
and then another one on which the error
was made that's going to be deep enough
to easily score roll blaze i mean guys
are just reaching out and hitting the
ball
300 feet for sac flies and for cabrera
are behind number 12.
there's a line driving the center field
that'll get down for a base hit a lot of
barrels off that bat
here's his dribble cabrera hitting from
the right as druba cabrera
drives one and see
you later he continues to swing the bat
beautifully from the right side and the
gnats have extended their lead to
7-1 1-1 to hanser
hit hard left field yeah there will be
no 0-4 tonight
into the corner pass soto hayes
streaking for third he gets the green
light he's headed home and it's an rbi
double
for answer alberto
well you just can't keep alberto down
can you mention he was over for three
yeah
hadn't really struck the ball too hard
at all but boy he barrels this one up
sound like a busted bat and out to left
center is going to drop
kibum scores checking in at third is jan
gomes
and the nationals lead eight to two and
it's a three hit night
for trey turner
eaton beats it right side gomes will get
off his feet for a moment
as he scores after that great slide
i gotta see if his teammates are telling
him oh
got a center cut fastball late for it
coming in austin hayes and nobody
catches it
there's a force out somewhere no no not
even at second trey turner scores and
it's ten to two
that ball hit hard down right field way
by garcia
he's going to get his first major league
rbis on that one
and the onslaught continues the nats two
more
and it's 13-2 nice debut
bounced up the middle trying to get the
bare hand on it
the orioles get a run infield hit dwight
smith gets an rvi
adam eaton jerked one down the line
right off of the scoreboard
pro blaze around to score easily and
adam eden will have hits his last
two times up again tonight the nets lead
14-3
and taylor gashes one for a base hit
that's off the second baseman felika
home to score as adam and the gnats
are just not failing to make great
contact all night long here
fastball challenged him defoe to his
left
why not in the night on another ground
ball very well played by wilmer defoe
and at 1206 in the morning this one is
over